DAN GALPIN: All right.
I'd like to thank you
all for being here.
We are going to be
talking about games.
And we have a tremendous
group of panelists up here.
But before I introduce
them, I wanted
to go a little bit into
what we're actually
going to be talking about.
And specifically, we talked
about games a little bit
in the keynote.
And one of the
things we mentioned
is that three out of every
four Android users play games.
So this is a huge community.
The last time we even
announced numbers,
we had over a billion
Android activations.
And our Play games services
have had a 100 million new users
in six months.
And some people say that is the
fastest growing network ever.
I just think it's
a lot of users.
And what does it
actually contain?
So we're talking about
Achievements, Leaderboards,
Multiplayer, and Game Gifts,
plus the two new services
we announced here at I/O, which
are Saved Games and Quests.
And I hope you all come.
There's another session
right after this,
which if you're
watching this on video,
it's all going to be
on video as well, where
Greg [? Cartell ?] goes
into a huge amount of detail
about what we're doing and our
motivations behind what we're
doing.
So I do hope you attend that.
It's going to be right after
this if you're here live.
Let's go through our panel.
We've got a great
group of people here.
I'm going to introduce
them very briefly.
So we start off Sourabh Ahuja.
He's from Glu Mobile.
Glu Mobile makes
awesome action games.
They really are one of
the first companies that
really got heavily
into Free to Play
We have Ari Kardasis
from Space Inch,
which is a really cool company.
You should definitely look up
the stuff that they're doing.
They just came out-- their
latest game, "Make It Rain,"
is awesome.
It's this crazy combination of
social commentary and spoof.
And he was also, of course, the
designer of "Disco Bees," which
is a really a
great game as well.
We have Guilherme
Lachaut from Gameloft.
I don't think I have to say
anything about Gameloft.
Their games are epic.
A bunch of them are on
the floor if you go look
at what we're showing
on Android TV today.
But just super, super
high-quality games
in every genre.
We have Keith Pichelman
from Concrete.
It's great the variety
of companies we have here
and the variety of
experiences we have here,
and the way all
of these companies
actually can
benefit by the stuff
we're doing around
gaming on Google Play.
And Concrete is a
25-person company.
They're from Minneapolis.
And they make the coolest
multiplayer bowling
game that is on Google Play.
It is really, really awesome.
And you should also
go check it out.
And then finally, we
have Lloyd Tullues.
He is here representing
Electronic Arts.
And I don't even
have to tell you
all of the things
Electronic Arts has done.
And again, a company that does
amazingly high-quality games
in every genre on Google Play.
So that is our
distinguished panel.
And we are going to be talking
not just about Play Game
services, but we're also going
to be talking about the game
industry in general
and Google Play.
So here is my first
question for our panelists.
And out of the
Play Games features
that you've integrated
into your games, which
have been the most valuable?
We'll start this
direction for now.
SOURABH AHUJA: So for
Glu and for our users,
I would say Cloud Save has
been the most valuable.
It helps us provide that
seamless experience.
People nowadays have their
phones, their tablets.
And now some of you
have the Android TV.
And you can take your
game back and forth,
the 2014 works
across all of them.
And it's free.
DAN GALPIN: All right.
ARI KARDASIS: So for us,
we're very, very small.
I'm a designer and a developer,
and I'm sitting here.
So anything that we can
get out of Google Play
game services that can eliminate
some of the overhead for us
is really super important.
In particular, achievements
is great for us,
because our games
are not multiplayer,
and it really helps
engagement a lot.
And yeah, it's been
a great experience.
GUILHERME LACHAUT: Thank you.
So hello everyone.
Talking about
Gameloft, so Dan said,
we have a white
portfolio of games.
And it's true that when it
comes to infrastructure, when
it comes to multiplayer
and Cloud Saver,
we're using our own system.
So we're mainly using
achievements and leader boards
in our games.
And I would say that when
it comes to achievements,
this is where we've seen
the highest engagement.
Most of our games
now are free to play.
And when you're
talking about users,
you first have user acquisition.
But then engagement and
retention is really important.
And so achievements have
achieved to bring competition,
and I think also the
fact that now there's
game profiles into the
main [INAUDIBLE] map
is very interesting,
because we think
it's going to continue this
trend of having people compete
for the games and being able
to see what their friends are
doing.
DAN GALPIN: I can
say personally,
I went and played
"I/O Hunt" here
at Google I/O, which is awesome.
If you guys who are
actually attending
haven't played it
yet, you should.
Partially just because there
are a lot of achievement
points to be had, and I leveled
up my profile right here
at Google I/O.
KEITH PICHELMAN: Yeah.
For us, our flagship game right
now is "PBA Bowling Challenge".
And we've integrated all
the game services right now,
and they've all been
really big for us.
But the biggest
by far is probably
the multiplayer and
the game services.
When we first released
"PBA Bowling Challenge",
it didn't have the
multiplayer mode.
We quickly started getting a
lot of fans, a lot of users.
And it was really
tough to keep up
with enough content
for all those users.
They kept on coming back
asking for more alleys and more
things unlocked,
more achievements.
By adding multiplayer,
that really
opened up to where people
would play forever.
They could play random
people, their friends.
And each game was
a little different.
It was kind of funny,
having it be real time.
We were actually looking
for an asynchronous type
of a multiplayer.
And real time has
been fantastic,
because it's actually exciting
to watch the other player
roll through the
different bowling balls
and kind of see, oh,
hey, look at that one.
Oh!
They used this ball.
And it's really been
great for engagement.
And you can see our
users talk about it a lot
and talk about how they
play against each other.
LLOYD TULLUES: So
we've been focusing
much more on achievements
and leader boards
through a great
many of our games.
And we've already seen
a tremendous amount
of value out of that.
Mainly because it's
a seamless experience
and a consistent experience
for users across our games.
But if we step
back a little bit,
the most valuable feature we've
gotten out of game services
is just having a
single sign on identity
that follows the user
between older devices.
So your achievements
follow you on your phone
versus your tablet, now on
your television and so on.
And just having that
experience across all of those
devices has been fantastic.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah.
For everyone who is
on the Android team,
we pretty much won't
play a game unless it
has some sort of
Cloud Save feature.
Because we're always
reflashing devices,
things are in development,
we're testing,
we're moving from
device to device.
Most of us have at least
a tablet and a phone.
And we want to play
on the best device
that we happen to
have at a time.
I'll tell someone,
this game is awesome!
And they're like, does
it have Cloud Save?
That's the first
question they'll ask me.
And so it really means a lot.
And I think we're seeing more
and more people out there
in the community
actually representing
a very similar kind
of demographic.
So the next question.
As we look into future launch
titles-- we're talking again,
I know they're talking about
Play game services a lot here,
but I'm hoping we can kind
of stretch the topics out
beyond this.
But if you look to
launch future titles,
how do you plan to
leverage what we're
doing in Play game services?
SOURABH AHUJA: So
we're going to keep
using what we do with the
[? team ?] leaderboards, Cloud
Save, retain those power users.
But the new features,
gifting-- we just
implemented it in
"Eternity Warriors 3".
We're experimenting
with that, made popular
by "Candy Crush" of course.
But again, we get a free
way of trying that system
through GPGS.
So that's happening.
We're actually putting in Quests
and snapshots of saved games
in "RoboCup" right now.
We're going live
early July, and we're
excited to see how the
metrics of those pan out.
And that's the
current plan for GPGS.
DAN GALPIN: And it's OK.
The packaged name for
saved games is snapshots.
So if you're actually
looking at the API,
that's what it looks like.
But the consumer
name is saved games.
ARI KARDASIS: So
our games tend to be
somewhat one player
at this point.
We're not really implementing
a lot of social stuff.
So I think moving
forward, not only
are we interested in
competitive gaming,
but also collaborative gaming.
We had a game about a year ago
called "Say the Same Thing",
which was a collaborative game.
And I think we didn't
ever quite figure out
how to monopolize on that.
And I think that Google
Play game services
is the kind of thing
where we can really
get people to engage
with their friends,
to work together to
achieve things in games.
GUILHERME LACHAUT: I think
when it comes to games,
we're really working on bringing
quality games-- HD triple
A games.
But also on the
social part of it.
And I think where Google
Play game services
is really interesting
is once again the leader
boards, the achievements,
and the new quests also
is very interesting for us.
Because it's going to
bring something new.
We wanted to bring something
unique to the Android
community, and this
is a great way for us
to continue launching it
with all our new games.
Implementing it all
the time, for us,
is a great way to really keep
it social, having sure everybody
can see what their
other friends are
doing, what games
they're playing.
And for us, it's a
key strategy to have
it implemented in most
our upcoming tiles.
KEITH PICHELMAN:
Yeah, we'll certainly
keep using all the Google
Play game services,
they've been really
valuable so far.
I think we're most
excited about Quests.
I mean, we really look
at Quests as being a way
to have live events.
If you look at a lot of the
big games out there now,
they have live events,
short events, longer events.
We're always looking at ways
to keep our users engaged,
keep the game with new content.
And by not having again to build
new alleys and tournaments all
the time, we can
do a lot, I think,
with Quests and
making those events.
LLOYD TULLUES: So I'm going to
go back to my previous answer
and build on that.
So when we are
looking at our users
and realize that they
have multiple devices
on different platforms,
we want to give them
a consistent across
all those devices.
So for, cloud saves
are particularly--
game saves are particularly
exciting, especially
with the new features
that are coming up,
that we can leverage across
different device types as well
as different platforms.
And so for us,
that's going to be
a very exciting
feature to leverage.
And I wanted to make
the comment too,
that it's interesting how
game services is almost
becoming its own game platform.
We can start leveraging
the users in Google Play,
as you guys are kind of
putting that competitive nature
against users that may
not even be friends.
And so as we build on
achievements in leader boards,
we can then leverage
Google's competitive features
and then keep engaging
users that way.
DAN GALPIN: Absolutely.
And I'll say,
completely, that part
of the reason I went off
and played "I/O Hunt"
here is that I was trying
to outdo Bob Meese's profile
score.
Bob Meese is the head of our
business development team here.
Point of honor.
Yeah, again, I think
what's really exciting too
is that we have the
services across to iOS.
We're launching actually
both saved games and Quests
simultaneously for not just iOS,
but also our cross platform C++
SDK.
And I'm really excited
about giving people
who have devices that are
in both families actually
the ability to play together
and the ability also
to bring saves from
one device to another.
All right.
Feedback from players.
What do they say
when you integrate
this, when you
don't integrate it?
Just kind of talk about it.
SOURABH AHUJA: So
it's mostly positive.
People love the fact the
competitive elements which
were missing before, or were
not going from one device
to another, so they like that.
There are some negatives, which
it was just touched about.
Like lack of it being
a gamer network,
where people struggle finding
their friends any inviting them
to play with because they're
not in the Google+ circles.
It's getting better, and I
think it will only get better
if everybody in this room starts
putting GPGS in their game,
so that we can all
leverage each other's users
and everybody's there,
so it's easy to find
your friends to play with.
ARI KARDASIS: Well,
I try to stay as far
from customer service as I can.
But we really start
games with Google Play.
So nobody's ever complaining
about it not being in there.
And it's been great.
I mean I don't think anybody has
anything negative to say to us,
and it's definitely
helpful for them.
GUILHERME LACHAUT: It's funny.
When it comes to gaming,
when users are happy,
they're just playing your game.
You don't hear them that much.
But actually, when you
don't implement the services
in your game-- so
we've implemented it
in most of our new games,
but sometimes legacy games
does not necessarily have it
at launch and need updates.
And so this is usually when
we hear our customers saying,
where are our achievements?
Where are our leader boards
from Google Play game services?
Because I think, once again,
it's creating a community.
And when it's there,
they're enjoying it.
But when it's not there,
they're not [INAUDIBLE] it.
So I think really now, it's part
of what users are expecting.
So we've never received
any complaints about it,
but I think it's
really something
that now users
are expecting when
they're playing on their games.
So it really has become a
truthful gaming experience
for users.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah.
One of the things I'm
excited about-- and going
from original feature, which
was app state, or game state,
to now we new have-- we have,
new, thank you, I can speak.
In terms of a game saves, it
actually shows up as a badge
now.
And that was a big problem.
A lot of people didn't
know, when people actually
implementing our
Cloud Save feature,
and now it'll be right up front.
Immediately I know, yes,
it's going to be there.
Yes, I know my state's
going to be preserved.
So I think it's a
really important thing
for users to be able to see.
KEITH PICHELMAN: Yeah.
Our users absolutely
love game services.
When we added multiplayer.
I mean they are definitely
now the most vocal
and have been playing
for the longest.
And then with achievements.
I mean it's become more
of a hobby for them
now, where if
something is wrong,
we hear about it immediately.
Or if you see somebody
who's hacked into the system
and gets a high score
in a leader board,
we definitely do
not find it first.
They tell us within about two
seconds that something's wrong.
They watch all that closely.
They love the multiplayer.
They love all the
different services.
DAN GALPIN: Now, your users
have actually gone and built
their own community
around the game.
KEITH PICHELMAN: Yeah.
It's really been interesting.
After the game was
out for a little bit,
we happened to run across that
somebody created a "PBA Bowling
Challenge" Google+ page.
Running it themselves.
And we just were kind of
were watching it for awhile,
until we finally joined
in to help them out.
I mean, they are so social.
They love talking to each other.
They're posting videos of how
they use different bowling
balls, they put different
spin on the balls.
And they spent a lot
of time in there.
In fact, that's
one of the things
we've learned from our users.
If they're that passion
about coming out and creating
this community outside the
game, that's obviously something
we should have inside the game.
DAN GALPIN: Have
you guys thought
about actually doing
a YouTube integration
and making it so users can
post videos over there?
KEITH PICHELMAN:
Absolutely, Dan.
Yeah.
It was funny, we actually
talked about that early on.
We were like, eh, do people
really want to post stuff?
A roll down the lane.
We actually decided
people weren't
going to be that
excited about it.
But we were absolutely wrong.
And yeah, we've been
researching exactly how
we're going to do that now.
DAN GALPIN: That's great.
LLOYD TULLUES: So for
us, no news is good news.
We've integrated game services.
And like I said earlier,
a great host of our games.
And we don't really
hear negative feedback
to kind of reiterate
the earlier points.
Which is, from our
perspective, fantastic.
And so for that
reason, we're just
going to keep integrating
more and more of the features
and see where we can take it.
DAN GALPIN: Awesome.
All right.
So challenges now.
Obviously, we talked about one.
First of all, we want
a better social graph.
That's the first
thing we mentioned.
What else can we do better?
SOURABH AHUJA: I think
now that everybody
is starting to put
it in, I'm hoping
that you guys have enough data.
So one of the challenges is
acquiring the right users.
And the recommendation
engine in Google Play games
can help everybody who's
making similar games in getting
the power users introduced to
the new game which is similar.
That will be really helpful
for the ecosystem, I think.
I'm not sure how you
guys are doing it,
but it'll be great if
that's happening right now.
DAN GALPIN: What do you
guys think of, in general,
the demographic features that
we put into the developer
dashboard?
SOURABH AHUJA: Yes.
The entire analytics,
it's very high level,
but it's very-- we all have, of
course, our analytics back end.
But the high level stuff you
get from Google Play games
analytics is very useful.
Like the demographics,
the retention,
all that information.
And now there is
more tools which
I think Ellie showed
of the Google Analytics
And actually measuring your
user acquisition campaigns,
which we're already
starting to look into today.
So I think all that
stuff is very helpful.
ARI KARDASIS: As
a developer who's
spread pretty thin
most of the time,
I think the biggest complaint I
would have is just sort of not
really knowing the full
landscape of what Google Play
game services can do.
I know that there's
a lot out there.
And we've done
achievements and sign in,
and I think we're working
on some leader boards.
But like demographics
and analytics,
I didn't really
know that existed.
So I think maybe
communicating with us better,
to know what's useful for maybe
different types of developers
at different stages in
their company cycle.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah.
I think we talked a lot about
the Play analytics features,
and we actually
announced it at GDC.
But we haven't gone
around trumpeting it.
And part of the reason
we didn't do that was it
wasn't quite done.
We didn't integrate
demographic features
until a few months later.
And we really felt that, when
you actually can not only see,
you know, look at the 5 day
and the 10 day and 15 day
retention, look at how that
compares with achievements,
then you can actually
see which demographics
you're resonating with.
That just adds a lot of
important data for our game
makers.
So I think now, we're
more excited to talk
about it as a feature.
GUILHERME LACHAUT: I
think with Gameloft
we've always tried
to be innovative.
So lots of innovative
features and social features,
we've tried to implement
them within our own back end.
So I think one of the challenges
was to all those features,
but not to duplicate what
we were already doing.
So it's finding
new, innovative ways
to bring additional
content to our users.
And it's worked great until now.
So we're really thrilled
about the services.
And I think one of the
main challenges we've
seen with the services
is the sign in process.
We think a great
evolution of the service
would be to ease and to
help users having kind
of an opt-in option, where they
could have a single sign on.
They would need
to just once say,
OK, I accept to sign
in into those services
and into all of my games and
never have to sign in again.
So I think this is, for
me, an evolution that
would be very beneficial
to the services.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah.
It's always a balance.
I think at Google,
one of things that we
take incredibly
seriously is privacy.
And it's always
making sure that we
give the best possible
service to our users
while making sure they
have absolutely the most
control over every piece
of information they share.
And I'm hoping we
can figure out a way
to strike that balance that's
even less obtrusive than we've
done already.
But I think that for us is
always going to be a challenge.
KEITH PICHELMAN: Yeah.
I can think of a couple things.
One minor thing would just
be with our leader boards
in the bowling game.
Most people, when they bowl,
they compare by average.
So we'd love to be able to
have a leader board type
thing with average, so they
can kind of go up and down.
Not just go up, like in points.
DAN GALPIN: We have leader
boards that can go only down.
And leader boards
that can go only up.
But we actually don't
have the ability
to have an average like that.
KEITH PICHELMAN:
Which would be great
if that really happened in
bowling, if your average always
went up.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah exactly.
KEITH PICHELMAN:
The other thing--
DAN GALPIN: Peak average.
KEITH PICHELMAN:
--is multiplayer
was the biggest service we've
added that's really helped out
our games quite a bit.
If we could add more to that.
Like right now we have
users all over the board,
as far as experience.
We've started out the game, we
actually had a cap of level 99,
and people blew through
that immediately.
And we raised it to--
I don't know why-- 199.
Of course that didn't
last very long.
And now today, we
have a capital of 999.
And people are
hitting that as well.
It's a challenge
when we match up
players that are say, like,
level 750 to somebody who's
level 10.
It doesn't make sense
at all, and they'll
drop out right away.
It'd be nice if we
had something where
if somebody was trying to
play a game, they're level x,
it started from that level
and kind grew out from there
to try to find somebody
at least that's
closest to that
level type of thing.
Or maybe even that level.
Maybe it's how good they are.
So maybe it's average or
something like that as well.
Or combination.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah.
So right now, you can
split up game matching
by variables that are fixed.
So you can say,
never match anyone
who's level 1 against
someone who's level 999.
But that means that
you could potentially
end up in a situation
where no one gets matched.
And so that's a challenge.
I think for us,
adding more variables
and making matchmaking
smarter is one of the things
that we really are
taking to heart
and are trying to
do going forward.
LLOYD TULLUES: So I want to
second the frictionless sign
in as well.
Anything that gets our
players into the game
and enjoying the content
without wall to get through
is fantastic.
But I also want to
add, for us, we've
got so many studios
internal, external to EA.
And we've got one
developer portal account
to rule them all.
So when we're talking
about something
as trivial as adding an
achievement or adding a leader
board, having to do that over
email with so many studios
all vying for the
same priority, it
gets very, very
difficult very quickly.
So what I would
really like to see
is automation tools, so that
our game teams can actually
build tools into their pipeline
so they can update whatever
achievement leader
board, whatever else
that they have, without us
being a bottleneck to them.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah.
And especially
when you're trying
to internationalize
all your achievements,
I know that's a lot of work.
I It was funny, when we were
first designing achievements,
we actually had an
internal debate.
And there was one side that
argued we should do everything
through XML and just have you
upload things to the portal.
And then the other
side was like,
but that will make it
really confusing for people
who are starting out.
And so I think
we're at that point
now where people understand
what achievements are,
they understand
what they contain.
And now it's time to actually
just simplify the process
and make it easier for everyone.
LLOYD TULLUES: Sorry.
Just one other thing I wanted to
add onto with our mini studios
problem.
We also have a very real
issue with game teams going
to look at data in the portal.
And while the
portal has a number
of excellent tools for
granular permissions,
we want to see that fleshed
out a bit more so our game
teams can log in and
look at their data,
see how their games
are performing,
especially in game services.
DAN GALPIN: Absolutely.
Yeah, that's a really
good point, too,
in terms of-- game services
are kind of locked out
from most people from seeing the
console, unless you're actually
a registered developer.
So people in support and
services can't see that stuff.
So that's another thing
for us take to heart
as we add more and more features
like statistics in there.
Let's see.
Next.
Oh, OK.
New features.
So this is we're
talking specifically
about saved games and Quests.
What are you most excited about
having your teams look at?
SOURABH AHUJA: So
for us, saved games
is kind of an extension of
what we were already doing.
So the fact that you
can have pictures and it
will show up in play games,
that is pretty exciting.
We saw a little glimpse of it
earlier on somebody's phone.
Even more excited about Quests.
We were already doing
some of it in our games,
which are more social.
So we're most excited
about Quests, I think,
and having some
sort of coop Quests
is going to be even more
useful down the line.
So that, to me, looks
pretty cool right now.
ARI KARDASIS: Yeah.
I mean we use saved games
in "Disco Bees", which
goes pretty well.
Not through Google Play
game services, but we will.
And in "Make it Rain", I
know that the second we
start doing that, people
are going to be using it
on two devices at
once, immediately.
And it's going to be a
challenge to deal with that.
There's a lot of
edge cases that we're
going to need to deal with.
So I think that
hopefully that can
manage that kind of situation
for us and make it smooth.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah.
I think that's always
a challenge, especially
in a game where there's
a chance element.
And there really is a
chance element in it.
Where all of a sudden,
you have people
who are playing on three or four
devices, and they're saying,
which one actually
does the best?
So I think that is hard.
And I think that unfortunately,
if you're allowing people
to play offline to begin with,
there's no great solution.
I think there's a number of
potential interesting solutions
to that one.
But definitely, how you handle
that conflict resolution
is tough.
GUILHERME LACHAUT: I think we're
really excited about Quests,
as well.
We already have time
limited events in our games.
But what's interesting
about Quests
is that you can set up
new Quests, of course,
all the time.
You can re-use them,
and you can also
change the kind of rewards
that are in the game.
So let's say, for
example, we're doing
a time limited
event in our game.
We can actually do a time
quest with achievements,
unique achievements
that can be unlocked.
So once again, it comes back to
using the achievement future.
But you can additionally use
the Quests to further enhance
this feature of the services.
And for us, we think that
time limited Quests like this
is really important.
Once again, for
engagement with our users,
just to have them
come back to the game,
keep on playing and having new
challenges within the game.
And we're looking forward,
also, to coop Quests,
which would be very
interesting thing.
DAN GALPIN: Quests to
me are just super cool.
How many people in the
audience here are actually
in the gaming industry,
just by a show of hands?
Great.
So one of the
things we've seen--
and I didn't even
introduce myself
at the beginning of this panel.
I've actually been doing
developer relations,
I've been a developer advocate
for four years here at Google.
And we've watched the
industry really shift.
And it started off
that we were in an era
where games were
one shot things.
Where people would play
them on their phone
for a couple of
weeks or a month,
and they'd go on
to the next game.
And now we're seeing that
all of the successful games
are actually really
games as services.
Almost every one of them
has a life cycle and an arc
and changes that are planned
over a long period of time.
And one of the
challenges when you
have a game that has a long
tail like that is actually
keeping it live for your users
and keeping your users engaged.
And so people had ops team that
would actually set up events.
And they would write all
sorts of code handle that.
And it really would
require a lot of resources.
So when we thought
about Quest, it was,
how do we keep people engaged
in a really cool way where
they don't have to build
their own back end,
and they don't have
to have an ops team?
So for us, it was
really the next step
in taking our services forward.
Anyways.
I just wanted to mention that.
Because it's something I'm kind
of passion about, actually.
KEITH PICHELMAN: Yeah.
We couldn't agree more.
So excited about Quests.
We're always trying to
keep our users engaged,
and they burn through
our content so fast.
And again, for us to build
a new alley, new lane,
new tournaments.
We have holiday tournaments,
like a Halloween tournament,
a Halloween alley.
It takes a lot of time
to build that out.
And what, we use it once a year.
So having Quests, having
these real time events,
will add a lot for our users
and keep them hopefully
very engaged.
And I can't wait to start
just trying them out
and try out different links,
different types of Quests,
and different types
of awards, and really
find out what our users enjoy.
LLOYD TULLUES: You said that
very well, I can't really
add on to-- that's perfect.
I would like to then
go back to saves,
which is my second
choice, thank you.
I'd like to say that the
game saves specifically
because, one, or, two reasons.
One, it's so easy for
us to actually save data
on to the cloud.
There's really not a whole
lot of work involved,
and we don't have to build our
back end for saving the data.
We don't have to
administer our own CDN
or go through all
that rigmarole.
So it alleviates a lot
of stress on our side.
And then the other side, too,
is it's fantastic for our users.
They know that if we
save data on game saves,
on the Google Cloud,
it's very well trusted.
It's there.
They know that even if
they uninstall the game
and come back later, their data
is still going to be there.
If we do our job
right, of course.
But I do like the
fact that our players
have that inherent
trust in Google
that we can then leverage.
And of course, like I said,
it saves our developers
to focus on the fun.
DAN GALPIN: I think when we
envisioned Play game services,
it was how to get developers
the best opportunity
to focus on making
games and let us
do some of the kind
of boring things,
like all this back end stuff.
To me, it's actually
really exciting.
But I know that there are
a lot of game developers
who would much rather add game
content than figure out how
to handle Cloud Save and have
the server infrastructure to do
that.
The thing that
I'm really excited
about with the new
Cloud Save feature
too is that we actually
are now making them social.
So other players
can actually see
the snapshot of your progress
and actually kind of figure
out how to compete
with you in that way.
When we originally
introduced the feature,
it was entirely non social.
We realized, how could we have
a feature of our game service
that didn't actually allow
people to be competitive?
And so that was one
of the driving forces.
The other thing is that everyone
said, we want bigger saves.
And so I'm happy to
say the new feature
allows for 3 megabyte saves.
They're actually tied through
a Google Drive account.
You can have multiple
saves as well.
So as much space as the
user's willing to give you,
you can have.
I think that's
really exciting too.
Especially when you think about
the scenario of all right,
maybe someone's playing
the game on three devices.
Well, you could do a conflict.
Or you could simply
say, well here
are your saves and
kind of, you know,
pick which you want to go on.
And that's pretty much it.
So this is beyond
Play game services.
And I think this is probably
the most open question.
And I want to go on
this for a while.
I've watched in the last four
years the business of gaming
change a lot on mobile.
So the question is, how
has it changed for you
in the past year?
What trends do you see
coming up in the future?
SOURABH AHUJA: So for
us, just the sheer amount
of growth and
downloads and revenue
on Google Play been amazing.
Like it has started to
catch up and the gap
is very narrow to iOS.
I'm happy that the finer
analytical minds at Glu
are now looking at taking deeper
dives into Android data, which
means that we're going
to be catering our games
also more towards what
the Android users like.
Or at least as much towards
what the Android users like.
So I'm pretty happy for like--
just the growth has just
been an amazing,
downloads and revenue.
ARI KARDASIS: Well,
today's the 26th, right?
DAN GALPIN: Yeah.
ARI KARDASIS: Yesterday is the
anniversary of us setting up
our first [? repo. ?] So
one year ago, "Space Inch"
was just a twinkle in our eye.
So happy birthday "Space Inch".
But a lot has changed
in the last year.
I mean we didn't release
the game until October,
and our first Android game
came out in, I think, March.
So it's all very new to us.
And we're accumulating knowledge
and learning everything we can
and really excited to engage the
old features which we haven't
gotten to, as well as the new
ones which are coming up soon.
DAN GALPIN: So when you look
forward in the next year.
Your team has produced a
really diverse set of games
in a very, very
short period of time.
What are the things
that are resonating,
in terms of the
games you've built?
ARI KARDASIS: I
think personality
is what we try to
get out of our games.
I mean there's a lot of games
out there that monetize well,
that have great engagement.
And I think that we need a
leg up, because we're small.
We don't have a big
analytics department.
We don't have a big marketing
department or UA department.
So we try to put a little
bit of heart and love
into everything we do
and make the games cute
and engaging and loveable.
And I think that
without services
that provide some
additional structure for us,
that would never
really be possible.
Because we'd have
cute and nothing else.
So it gives us that leg up.
DAN GALPIN: It's
super exciting to me
that a company can go from
a repo-- getting created--
to having three successful
games across multiple platforms
in a year.
I think that says
a lot about where
we are in this
industry and a lot
about the opportunity
that's still there.
GUILHERME LACHAUT: The
real question would be,
what hasn't changed in
over a year on Google Play?
I mean, the story itself
changed completely.
A whole new UI, new types of
collections, algorithmic base.
So I would say really, like it's
great to see the Google Play
store catching up.
So really tremendous results in
terms of downloads and really
the gap decreasing
in terms of revenue,
as well, with other
key platforms.
So it's been a great
2013 year and hopefully
a great 2014 year
going even further.
I think for us, we're really
looking into new platforms.
So Android TV is
one, but we're also
excited whether
Android [INAUDIBLE],
with Android [? Auto ?].
I mean there's so
many new ways to try
to reach our users to try to
transform the user experience
and to bring new values to
games that-- I mean we're really
looking forward into,
once again, innovation
and seeing what we can bring
to users with our games.
DAN GALPIN: So as we talk
about this past year, what
have you seen in
terms of Asia and it
being a force in your games?
I know it's one of the
challenges for game makers
that are outside
of Asia is actually
kind of cracking
into that market.
How has that worked
for your team?
GUILHERME LACHAUT: So we're
really a global company.
So we do have offices
all around the world.
But it's true that
when you look at Asia,
it's a really specific market.
It has its own customs.
The users are really playing
different types of games.
So as a publisher, I think for
us it's really important-- what
we're trying to do is
really to adapt our offers.
So content of our games,
pricing, and the way
we're addressing them.
We went from being
global to trying
to offer the same service,
then localization,
and now it's really offering
a customized experience
to those kinds of markets.
DAN GALPIN: Cool.
KEITH PICHELMAN: Yeah.
So Concrete Software, we've been
around for almost 11 years now,
making mobile games.
It's been quite a ride.
And the biggest change it
seemed like over the long haul
has been pricing.
We started off, we were selling
mobile games for $20 a shot.
And we got press
down, kind of went
to advertising a little bit.
But then, really,
this last year we
had to make a fundamental
shift, where we really
had to start thinking
about our games
as not just being a
product to get out the door
and trying to make a great
game, get a good review.
But our games are now services.
We really think about, when make
a game, that this is a service.
And that's where
Quests will come in.
Or we can add a lot more
content for our users.
But yeah, this
last year-- we used
to release maybe six,
seven games a year.
And now, this last
year, we released one.
It's really been a
challenge to make sure
that we retain our users, that
we always have new content,
and that we really think
more as a service company.
LLOYD TULLUES: So for us, it's
really been a mindset change.
If we're going to talk about
Asia just for a second,
in the past-- I've been in the
industry for 13 some odd years.
And when we make
a product, you go
through localization efforts.
You just translate everything
and you kick it out the door
and you open the rest
of the world likes it.
But the mindset change on
our end, specifically now,
is it's not just
about localization.
It's about culturalization.
Taking a game and really
adapting for the Asian market
in a way that resonates to them.
And oftentimes, we
get a product that's
very different from the one that
we have in the United States.
And so that's been a very,
very big change for us.
And then we've also gone through
the same learnings in terms of,
you just can't go to the old
way of doing things, which
was make a thing, ship
a thing, and then pray.
You now make a thing,
you ship a thing,
and then you keep
on building it.
As you learn what
your users like,
you get into the
behavioral play patterns.
You see what content
they really enjoy,
and you keep building on that.
You just keep on making the game
better for many years on end.
DAN GALPIN: So when you
guys think of a game,
how many updates in the
future are you guys thinking,
in terms of when you have a
game that you know is a service?
How far in the future
are you thinking?
LLOYD TULLUES: Very long.
We will plan for years on end
for it a successful title.
SOURABH AHUJA: I'll quickly
comment on Asia, too.
On the culturalization
part, it is the key.
We've had one or two
successes, but we've
realized-- I personally
went there, too,
and we partnered with companies
like [INAUDIBLE] in giving them
our game engines and
letting use their expertise
for the Japanese audience to
adapt to the monetizations.
Like the live events,
those kind of things,
which work really well.
The characters, I think
that culturalization
is the key to success
in Asia right now.
DAN GALPIN: When you talk
about culturalization,
are you talking about changes
to marketing, to game play,
to just character design?
How deep do you end up going?
SOURABH AHUJA: We're going
pretty deep for this project
with [INAUDIBLE].
They really liked
our 3-D engine we
had for our game
"Heroes of Destiny."
And we like what they
are doing, of course.
So everybody knows
how successful
their games are in Japan.
So we've hired
another developer.
So they are working with them
for changing the monetization.
They're changing
their characters
to give them a
different look and feel
which appeals to the
Japanese audience.
The level design.
Everything is changing.
It's just the core engine,
the 3-D engine, is the same.
But everything
else, the gameplay,
is changing to suit
the Japanese audience.
DAN GALPIN: I think it's
been really interesting.
We've seen both directions.
We've seen companies
from Asia make strides
into European and US markets.
And it's always been, how do we
take something we know works,
in terms of a general concept,
and bring that same concept
to these markets in a way
that's palatable and exciting
for them?
And there have been
a couple of games
that have really done
that successfully.
But it's hard, there's
no question about it.
So in terms of game success.
How do you define success
in terms of a game?
SOURABH AHUJA: So keeping
users in the game.
So the retention.
The money follows.
I mean, we can see even
from chat apps, right?
If you keep users
in your app, you
will get eventually paid for it.
So retention is the key.
There's so many apps
and games out there.
Users have short attention span.
Asian users have even
shorter attention span
then the Western users.
So it's key to keep
them entertained.
Keep the updates coming.
Plan out at least a year
in ahead of what content
we're going to keep.
Because they eat
up content fast.
And then move on to the next
one if you don't give them
something fast when they're
done with those three levels.
Make sure you have the fourth,
fifth, sixth, ready to go.
ARI KARDASIS: Well,
of our three games,
they've sort of enjoyed
success in very different ways.
Say the same thing was
kind of a critical hit.
The Disco Bees
monetized very well.
It's kind of a sturdy game
that is what you want.
And Make It Rain was kind of
a runaway, viral sensation.
So we don't know.
In a nutshell, we
like the process
of experimenting and finding
new ways to be successful.
And I think that
as we go forward,
we'll try to take
things from each game,
combine them into
super games that
are successful in
two or three ways.
Yeah, it's always
different for us.
GUILHERME LACHAUT:
I think longevity,
when it comes to gaming.
We have games like "World at
Arms" or "Order & Chaos Online"
that have been live for
more than two years.
And we're still bringing new
content all the time to users.
And seeing those
users still being
focused on playing
the game every day.
The retention, the
engagement in those games
that are celebrating their
two plus years, anniversaries,
is very impressive.
And this is, I think,
what's the most interesting
with the switch to
freemium is that now,
not only games have
a very long life.
I mean, you don't even know
now when you release a game.
It could still be live in
five years with new content.
So that's really what was
the thrill with the industry,
is that everything
is changing so fast.
And there's always
new challenges.
So for us, really
longevity and being
able to have our games
live after two plus years
and then being able to
bring new content to them
is really a sign of success.
KEITH PICHELMAN: Yeah.
We look at the same things,
especially early on in a game.
We look for engagement
and longevity
and make sure that it's
a fun game, that people
are enjoying it, you know?
We're looking at the reviews
and see how people react.
And we do a lot of testing
and see, you know, people,
do they want to play it again?
Did they not put
the device down?
Things like that.
I would say, Concrete
Software, being
that we're a smaller
company, 25 people,
we are very careful
about our games.
And we want to make sure
that they make money.
And so we look closely
at the lifetime values.
We also look at how
much time and cost
that goes into
the games as well.
Like "PBA Bowling Challenge",
we spend a lot of time and money
keeping it up, creating new
events and things like that.
Where we do have other games
that we call very successful,
like our "Aces Spades"
and "Aces Gin Rummy" where
we don't have to
spend a lot of time.
It's actually ad based.
And we keep them updated.
We keep them working
on the latest devices
that we don't necessarily
spend a lot of time and efforts
to create live events
or things like that.
DAN GALPIN: I think in the
early version of Android,
the most popular-- I don't
know how many of you were back
in the early days of Android.
The most popular game
on Android market
was actually a solitaire game.
Because everyone
wanted solitaire,
and it was about
50 kilobytes long.
So it was a no brainer, everyone
just kept it on their device.
I'm not sure how much
people actually played it,
but it was on every
single person's phone.
And there are
games that are just
going to be perennial
things, that people are going
to want to keep there, to have
that little experience all
the time.
Versus then there
are things that
are more engaging and
require more depth.
And that's a different
kind of success.
LLOYD TULLUES: So
we look very heavily
towards engagement and
retention metrics as well.
We love creating fantastic
content for our players.
And so we will look closely in
terms of what they're consuming
and what they come back
to, so we build upon that.
So that's one of
the big ways that we
measure the success
of our games.
But one of the things that
I really like looking at
is the peripheral emerging
behaviors of our users outside
of the game.
So when they start
creating content.
Like videos, or
they go on forums
where they create
strategy guides, right?
And they start sharing ideas
and approaches with one another.
That's how we know, OK, we're
actually on to something here.
And we can possibly
build on that.
So that's always
very, very exciting.
And then we've got other things,
but usually the rest follows.
DAN GALPIN: I think one of
the most exciting things
about mobile right
now is the ability
to directly interact with your
players and cycle really fast.
I think for me, the coolest
thing about Google Play
is you can come up with
an idea, make a change,
and have it out to
users within an hour.
And that's crazy fast.
You think about the console
era of just a few years ago.
You'd finish your game.
You'd send it off for testing.
You would actually
get burnt into discs.
A month or two months
later you would get it out.
And then maybe you
could patch it later.
And now we're in this
position where you can just
continue to tweak and engage.
And I think from a product
perspective, actually,
for outside of Play
Games, it's actually
Tag Manager is the one that
I'm super excited about,
to be able to actually analyze
trends and then tweak games
very, very, very quickly
based upon those trends.
I think it's super exciting.
Well, we're about out
of time for the panel.
But I wanted to
give each one of you
a chance to say
one last statement
about the future of games.
And I know I'm putting
you all on the spot here.
SOURABH AHUJA: Future of games.
Google Play.
Keep putting GPGS in your games.
I think we have
a long way to go.
We're caught up a
lot, but there's still
a lot of room for growth.
A lot of countries which are
getting their smart phones now,
and they're all going Android.
So I'm happy.
Things like what Dan just said
makes the iOS guys jealous,
because we can turn
around things much faster.
So this is the platform to be.
ARI KARDASIS: I think
that, going forward,
I mean at least for us is going
to be smaller, faster games
that we put out in
a couple of months.
And with infrastructure
from Google,
we can make something
that works and monetizes
and has all these features
even in a really, really short
period of time, so that we
can just make a lot of games.
GUILHERME LACHAUT: I
think innovation really
is something we
want to focus on.
Really trying to always bring
something new to the market,
to users.
This new experience.
So I would say really for us,
it's going to be innovation.
Keep on doing great days
and trying to have our users
have the most fun they can.
KEITH PICHELMAN: I
think building a game
to last for a really long time.
Looking at games
being a service.
Making sure you
build infrastructure
so that it's ready to be
around for 5 years, 10 years,
instead of just building a
game to be around for a year
is going to be huge
for the future.
LLOYD TULLUES: I've been in
this industry for 13, 14 years
and I absolutely love it.
There's no other industry that
I can think of that innovates
so quickly.
And whenever anybody puts
something new and interesting
out there, my thought process
is kind of put a game on it.
And so, it's
phenomenally interesting.
We're looking at Android TV,
we're looking a smart watches,
we're looking at Google glass.
It's all these interesting
platforms, you wonder,
can I put a game on this?
Does this make sense?
Where this is going?
And if it doesn't
work now, will it
work two, three
years down the line?
So yeah, innovation is
the name of the game here.
And it's absolutely
exciting in that way.
You cannot take your eye off
of what's happening around you,
whether it relates
to games or not.
Because who knows?
Android TV and Glass and smart
watch and games on your plate
might be the next big thing.
Who knows?
It's going to be exciting.
DAN GALPIN: Thank you.
I wanted to put up this
slide a little early, right?
Because I wanted to make
sure you had time to see it.
If you want to find out
about Play game services,
you can go to that link.
Also, if you wanted to do
feedback on this session,
you can use that QR code or
that really tiny, tiny URL
underneath there.
Please let us know
what you think.
Please tell us what
you want us to cover.
We have a lot of great
content here at I/O.
And I want to thank you
again all for being here.
And I want to thank our
panelists, especially,
for coming in and doing this.
[APPLAUSE]